kg fait sens et qui le fait vous vous
sûr que non regardez c'est grossier non
non non surtout pas vous le faites pas
vous dîtes à bout le fait non nation la
19e alféa non mais c'est vrai que les
personnes à qui son influence sur les
réseaux peut-être le fond mais moi
j'essaye d'être un maximum et vous
n'êtes jamais filmés en faisant mais ça
va pas toi mon frère oui mais elle fait
plus mais alors de quoi tu fais plus con
ce bétail mais je sais que votre mec le
fait beaucoup mais n'a pas la dernière
fois il m'a envoyé un texto
bon ok je m'emmerde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et tout ça vous ne faites pas mais non
c'est vrai non bon alors on peut on peut
faire un break d'une petite heure on
peut faire un break du petit jorge
battle super bright que l'on peut faire
un break d'une minute non mais vous à
moi je suis très très partisan de cette
pratique mais je trouve ça arrange les
deux bad de regarder les son téléphone
en même temps la fille en général se
demande de regarder son téléphone comme
celle tweets sont en effet des tweets
ensuite sur sept tweets vous dire ce
n'était pas lui mais il faut dire que
qu'elle prend son pied que c'est génial
et c'est la voie la main on voyait
hashtag vous et moi pendant ce temps là
je mets un film sur le dos un ipad et je
regarde un film dont il faut s'occuper
[Applaudissements]
non moi pour moi le portable doit être
bannie de la shoah non oui comme la télé
absolue moyens personnels à mettre en
symbiose en harmonie faussurier éviter
le portable est enceint blues ya l'état
ni dans votre chambre
moi il ya partout des téléphones à ces
partis chez moi avec mes bras tendus non
mais j'ai une télé bien entendu je serai
moitié moi je moi je suis obligée
d'avoir la télé pourquoi après théo
c'est quoi tout cela nuit avait trop de
la lavande et d'huiles oui tu lis un
bouquin dit ouais mais sa jolie déjà
toute la journée
c'est beau jusque là tu abandonnes avait
oublié je m'entends avec crime tout ça
et tout chanteuse zaz est en train de
dormir dehors dehors avec les écrans
c'est terrible pour la libido parce que
justement vous avez plus d'image
issanchou il avait honte asthme et terry
pour la libido davidovna bideau oui bob
ce pas ton problème sans problème vous
avez fait une fois avec fatou ah non pas
avec fatwa non non il s'affaissa avec
fat ou non mais sauf si c'est vous qui
appelez à oui c'est un peut-être abalo
[Rires]
non pour essayer non merci donc à manger
mais j'avais eu pas mal de truc c'est
que j'ai des amis
tous sont emmerdés silva m'est arrivé
une fois elle voulait pas envoyer un sms
un jour et j'essaie de vous appeler et
on voit si le dire c'est cyril répond ce
serait bien la première fois que vous
répondez à mes sms et jausiers seuil est
d'accord essayez un jour je le sais mais
ça vous l'avez déjà fait une fois alors
oui il ya longtemps j'avais une urgence
pour le travail je savais que j'avais
envie de voir la 2de dans la mobilité de
ma compagne voilà de faire l'amour mais
je savais que j'avais une urgence pour
le travail je devais partir je les fais
quand même ça a sonné j'ai répondu parce
que je devais n'ont su fait jeter ça
ouais ouais la favela mais vers la
turquie n'attendez pas que ça non c'est
possible vous alors non merci pas
toujours mono parce que les gens aiment
sich où on nous donne pas portable
[Applaudissements]
ouais le ballon contré mais que je me
les achète d'accords oem saisonnières
alors alors il est important que je peux
pas parce qu'un rapport c'est moyenne de
8 minutes et moi ça me prend plus de
temps pour faire un sms parce que je
mets la ponctuation l'orthographe c'est
mort je suis surprise qu'on s'en sert
que pour faire des sms parce que vu
qu'un iphone sa vie moi moi je connais
plein de femmes qui ont d'autres non
[Rires]
mais c'est trop tnt un très beau témoin
alors je veux dire autant les autres je
m'en foutais un peu
franchement autant là delphine non mais
keane qui ne décroche pas le téléphone
même pendant sa voilà quoi il ya un
appel à 13h gens qui rentrent mais bien
sûr même si c'est pour faire une minute
tacon raccrochons consentir ouais bah
ouais et roger du rien mais d'ailleurs
roger vergé des gentils roger prévient
sont aujourd'hui on est d'ordinaire on
est tellement tellement connectés donc
quand le téléphone sonne juste à sur la
table de nuit ben on décroche trois
sports c'est dramatique
aïe aïe à l'auteur sans rigoler --- on
lui a annoncé de nouvelles on dirait
qu'on lui a annoncé qu'elle allait
arrêter vidéo qu'accepter dramatique
vous oui bah des foires malgré toi la
blache par le couple allait de la
maintenant là parce que ça avance alors
donc dites moi non j'imagine que si on
est en conversation téléphonique avec
quelqu'un ça peut être très excitant
même temps de le faire est de rester
normal au téléphone ah ouais un
joaillier patron bah je sais pas vous
annoncer ma mère
non mais non ouais non la wii série ça
est d'essayer d'un de mathieu ouais
alors moi c'est un peu spécial c'est
qu'aucun alors lui la taurine histoire
est depuis sans rigoler lui c'est non
mais c'est un truc de fou n'en sais que
c'est un jour une plaquette un message à
l'aqmi de 10 amis gay à peu près en soit
tous les week-ends ses meilleurs potes
et two way et c'est vrai que moi je suis
hyper prudent entre nous on est hyper
prêteurs n'a généreuse on est généreux
on se prête tout et il ya la journée de
la générosité d'ailleurs et donc c'est
vrai que parfois comme je couche avec
quelqu'un et si c'est un très bon coup
je fais j'écris juste rejoignez nous
voilà bah oui ben soigner nouba oui cdp
alors tu entends tu vas me dire qu'il ya
des mecs en fait ils sont patrouille
dans le quartier
[Rires]
libratone g battable
gildas est battable
on doit intervenir 15 avenue du maréchal
juin apparemment c'est braaten ronnie va
on est en ville en normandie vont aider
du candidat on lui rien n'est plus faux
merci on envoie un message
oui bah oui ses couilles j'ai tenté j'ai
toi tu regardes de bonne conduite sur
soi rejoignez-nous tu sais que ton pote
en train de faire l'amour que ça a
beaucoup tu vas tu arrives tu participes
bah écoutez ma brave ont fait d'être
généreux si les bassins cercueils des
deux généraux franchement la q2
d'ailleurs de l'amitié ça alors la
prochaine fois que vous vouliez
rejoignez nous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]